une série d'explosions suivie de
violents incendies une fois de plus les
habitants de Kief sont réveillés en
pleine nuit par le fracas des bombes
russes l'armée ukrainienne dit avoir
abattu 10 missiles ennemis qui fonçaient
sur la capitale l'UR des bris ont tout
de même frappé des habitations et causé
des départs de feu les blessés se
comptent par dizaines pour j'ai entendu
une explosion à 3h du matin nous
dormions tous puis nous avons entendu
une sirène j'ai couru dans la chambre
des enfants le ver volé en
éclat c'est comme ça que cela se passe
aujourd'hui au 21e siècle ils peuvent
lancer des roquettes sur les ukrainiien
la Russie est un pays voisin c'était un
pays frère nous avons vécu en paix
pendant tant d'années et aujourd'hui ils
détruisent notre nation et ont déclenché
cette guerre ce lundi déjà la capitale
ukrainienne était ciblée par des
missiles privant d'électricité une
centaine de foyers une attaque
informatique a également mis h service
une partie du réseau téléphonique et de
la défense antiérienne sur le terrain
dans le donbas à l'est du pays les
forces de Kiev se sont félicité de la
reconquête de ce teréril mais ici comme
dans le sud le front est figé depuis des
mois les troupes russes tiennent et
continuent d'infliger de lourdes pertes
à une armée ukrainienne qui peine à
garder
espoir avant la guerre j'étais maçon
mais j'ai pris cette décision par
vengeance mes proches ont souffert et je
voulais me
venger il n'y a tout simplement pas
d'autre issu mais j'ai peur que notre
état disparaisse nous devons faire
quelque chose avec l'arrivée de l'hiver
compliquant le mouvement des troupes le
front risque de se figer encore un peu
plus pour les mois à venir seul les
drones les missiles et le contrôle du
ciel semblent pouvoir départager les
armées russes et
ukrainiennes